I watched myself die I wanted to be a
choir director
every hope every dream that I had had
was wrapped around that Center idea that
I could hear and when that left I had no
idea how to live anymore
I lost my hearing when I was 18 and
that's where listening to music stopped
I've never heard Taylor Swift sing I've
never heard Adele's sing
I work really hard to feel things I
always have my shoes off when I perform
because as the drums go or the bass goes
you feel it through the floor and that
keeps me in time and I was born with
near perfect pitch so I used that skill
mixed in with muscle memory to feel
where I am and then just sing
I create songs all the time I just have
something in my head so I just sing it
in my recorder and then I'll send it off
to other people and they can chart it
for me they can tell me what the notes
are cuz I can't tell I wouldn't be able
to close my eyes to tell you what it was
it's just a ghost music is a ghost
there it is I had at that time I spent a
really long time of my life being afraid
but sound still exists you can feel
music everywhere you just focus
come walk my friend with me to play
slowing always dream you know how it
feels to be right where you're supposed
to be oh hold me forever
come walk my friend with me to place now
we always strained